all right spicy
hi spicy uh where are you from where
where'd you grow up chicago illinois and
you're still
living there yes tell me about your
childhood you had both your parents when
you were a kid
absolutely raised in a very good home
with uh nine siblings and i'm the
youngest of nine
my mom and my dad they were married for
57 years when he met her
she was 15 years old he was 25. and they
were together up until the day he passed
away
wow sounds like a good childhood yes no
abuse nothing crazy
no so how far did you go to school i
graduated from 12th grade
what kind of kid were you in high school
pregnant what kind of kid were you in
high school
um comical
um a great sense of humor
i was a great kid everybody loved me
and still do today so how did you
get introduced to the game because well
actually to be totally honest um
me growing up as a as a as a child
i can remember my mom will always tell
her daughters
if a man like you well enough to sleep
with you he should like you well enough
to help you
so i guess that's the intake i got from
behind that so that's what started me
into the game
and i um i also
had i can say two two p's
and i'm pretty sure you know you're
familiar with that um
and to be totally honest that didn't go
well because
you know sometimes they let they
lead you to believe things that's not
really happening and see i'm about
me and mine when i'm down and i'm loyal
you know to the utmost so when i wasn't
getting treated fairly
i left that and then i i started to um
continue to do what i was doing on my
own
and how did that go it went well it went
well i had no one putting their hands on
me
i had no one just trying to degrade me
for doing something
to help them you understand what i'm
saying
and um you know sometimes
we as people we look for love in the
wrong places
and during that time that's what i was
doing but when i began to love myself
wholeheartedly
i began to recognize my words and who i
was as a woman first
so yeah that's how i began to get in the
game
and you're saving money now pardon me
you're saving money
yes yeah whereas when you when you when
you were working with pimps
was that not the case no i was giving
him every dime i made you know what i
mean
because i mean that's what i was taught
you know um
being in the game that's what i was
taught and i that's how i thought it
should go but
what is the premise i mean so so for
what does the girl get out of it that
what does a girl think she's gonna get
out of that she thinks she's gonna get
the finer things in life you know like
homes and
nice cars you know pretty much you know
um
i was so to dream and i brought it but
when i became
whole with myself and began to find out
who i was
and accept who i was cold harley i began
to have
self-love first because self-love is the
best love you know what i mean
um people can tell you anything you know
and you tend to believe it because
you're
you're thirsty for that uh attention
you're thirsty for someone to
give you the love that you needed you
know or that you desired
but when you begin to um just separate
yourself from
negative people places and things you
begin to grow and so i don't regret
anything i went through because it was
all a learning lesson for me
what didn't kill me just made me
stronger and only the strong survive
you've had uh bad experiences doing this
been arrested
beaten up um well actually i never been
arrested
i guess that was a way of uh god
keeping me shield because he had
something better for me you know what i
mean so
no i've never been arrested but as far
as um beating yes
i've been beaten yeah i've been being to
a point where
i had to have emergency surgery
i had a surgery um i can say this was
about
maybe 10 to 12 years ago where i had a
cyst already and then i was being so bad
by this particular p
that i had to end up in a hospital
i did eternal bleeding the day of the
surgery which caused me to have
another surgery the following day so i
had a back to back surgery
and i had to have a blood transfusion
behind that
it took me almost six months to walk
again so look at me now i'm grateful
i made it through you know what i mean
yeah do you have kids
absolutely i have two daughters i have a
37 year old and i have a 32 year old and
i'm not a grandma
you don't look old enough to have a 37
year old dog yeah i'm not a grandma i
know i get that a lot you know
and uh have drugs ever been a part of
your scene no
you stayed away from that yes
and doing this for a living i mean do
you ever get depressed or
you know no because actually i'm just
going to be totally honest with you and
i'm going to give it to you in a raw
because that's how i
am um i work a square drop
now but this is my side hustle
i'ma get it if i can you know yeah i've
met a few girls that
didn't want to do interviews but they
they said yeah i work as a nurse
yeah but you're out here yeah i like
doing it yes
you enjoy it well actually um to be
totally honest
sometimes i've i've had dates where i
didn't even have to do anything because
i guess it's just my personality and my
openness and my being honest you guys
like hanging out with you
yeah they just like hanging out with me
you know and they'll pay you for that
absolutely
what have you learned about human nature
by doing this well
what did i learn about human nature what
i learned about human nature is
you have to focus on
god himself first because
a lot of people set their alarm clocks
to wake up and things of that nature
that's not the case he's waking you up
he's um keeping me
safe he's keeping me um he's been
protecting me throughout the game you
know and
i'm just grateful because it's sometimes
where
i didn't dipped into a guy's pocket as
far as pickpocketing and things like
that
he kept me safe because if they had
caught me they could have killed me
you know what i mean so i'm just
grateful through it all
yeah how do you define success success
is
i define the success as
it comes from the heart you know what i
mean you can be the richest person in
the world
you can have all the jewels all the
material all the flashy things but if
you're not happy with success
with yourself you can't be successful
because success comes from within
you know you're loving yourself is first
of all you know people feel as though
cause they got this amount of money that
they're rich
my riches comes from within and my life
experience has taught me to be that way
do you find this doing this kind of work
boosts your self-esteem or does it also
undermine at the same time well
to be totally honest i'm just gonna give
it to you from my perspective
it's um i wouldn't say that it boosts my
self-esteem because i have very my
self-esteem i'm very very high
and my life experience has taught me to
be that way so i don't need a booster
honey i'm there
i i mean it's the fast money to be
totally honest
it's the fast money the extra the extras
you know
yeah that's what that is and do you
think a lot of the i think the majority
of the girls i've talked to and the guys
are addicted to the life oh no i'm not
addicted
you know i'm not addicted because you
can put it down
of course of course i don't
i don't wake up every day saying oh i
gotta go do this as far as being a
prostitute and things of that nature
i don't do that yes i put it down before
but like i said if
um if it's there and i can get it i'm
gonna get it
it's not like this is the life that i
live on the daily waking up
thinking about how i'm gonna get my next
dollar from the trick and things of that
nature
that's not my lifestyle anymore but yes
if i can get it
i'mma get it you have a very strong
personality i'm sure that helps you
survive and do this yes
absolutely absolutely this line of work
is not for every girl nah
um they can't a lot of women can't
stomach what i've been through
you know like i said i owe it all to god
because i'm grateful he'll allow me to
see my way through that sometimes you
know when you're in this lifestyle
the girls begin to play um the victim
and things of that nature because
a person only do to you what you allow
them to do and those things were done to
me because i
allowed that but not anymore so i mean
i'm grateful today
i'm loving me and it's all good do you
think
is i mean it's it's it's a questionable
lifestyle
you know it's you're doing something
that's illegal in the united states
at least and it's it
it's dangerous absolutely absolutely a
lot of people will be watching this
going like
you're crazy for doing this you're
intelligent and you're you have another
career
why do you even do it like i explained
to you before
and i'm gonna say this again sir it's
the fast money you know the extras
that's helping me because i'm single
you know what i'm saying it gets hard on
me sometimes you know i don't have
anybody saying
here baby take this and put it on a bill
here baby do this with this
i'm by myself you know what i'm saying
so i have to do what i have to do
in order to survive because um to be
totally honest
you know my my paychecks and stuff it
pays the bills and this
that any other one oh i mean what girl
doesn't want
extra you know what i'm saying do you
recall your very first time
doing this for money pregnant do you
recall your very first time
absolutely absolutely i recall my first
time
doing this and then sweaty you said that
because i was just talking about this
experience
i can say i was about
i would say 17 years old
i was walking to the store i see this
guy this flashy guy with all the jury
you know those things excited me then
but not today see the guy with the
flashy jury and he was
driving a champagne color excalibur with
the kid on the side
and so i'm going i'm walking to the
store and he's like slowly driving and
he's blowing his horn
things of that nature so by me being in
that neighborhood the neighborhood was
like
one big happy family and one of my mom's
friend was sitting on the porch as this
guy was blowing
so i'm doing like this because i don't
want her to see me right i'm like
come around the corner so he comes
around the corner and he meets me at the
store
and we talk and he offered me um five
hundred dollars
and i mean me being the type of person i
was at that time i mean
eight seventeen years old and a guy
offered you five
hundred dollars just to go with him for
an hour or so
yeah i did it and that's where it
started
from the walk to the store
yeah that's where it started how do you
think all these years working the
streets has changed
i never really worked the street i
always um define that what do you mean
by honey i
i didn't mean working the streets
literally i meant having sex for money
well to be totally honest honey
me myself i really didn't have sex for
money and i'm just gonna be honest
i would give a [ __ ] before i would
let someone go inside of me because i
kind of always felt like
this is my temple and everybody
shouldn't be there you know what i'm
saying so
yes i would easily give a [ __ ] cover
that up with a condom don't knock them
off
once they're knocked off they're dead so
they're not going to want to go in you
you know what i mean so
that's how i save myself from sleeping
with a lot of guys i'll give them some
head and go on knock them out baby
get them right that's what i do get them
right right and then all right so how
how is that uh
over doing this over all these years
changed you um
because most girls don't do this
pregnant most girls don't do that
i know most girls don't do this because
i'm not most girls you're not
i'm i'm not most girls you know
but like i said um i def it's a job to
me
you know i don't take it personal i
don't let um it get in the way of me
being
who i am as far as um the relationship i
have with god
i don't let that get away and then some
people will say she's talking about god
and this and that other but
he knows that none of us are perfect you
know so
and he knows my heart that's the most
important thing because
satan he deals with your mind has
has it changed the way you view men no i
can't allow that to change
the way i view men because all men are
not the same that's true
you know i can't put up this big
building because i've been mistreated by
me
and don't allow myself to um
be able to receive that man that's for
me
you know i can't do that i'm cheating
myself but you're you're you're
very attractive female and you're single
do you think this lifestyle gets in the
way of you meeting a guy no honey
because i'm gonna tell you something
i've met one and he understands me
he have no ups and downs about what i do
because we're open like that as far as
our communication
and i'm loving on this one right now you
know i'm just keeping 100 i'm loving on
this one right now
he's an amazing guy um
i don't know if i should say his name or
not but oh my god
for me right i mean he's like he's so
understanding
and you know he's like team deborah
you know what i'm saying team spicy he's
so for me
because he he understands
we don't have a problem about this
because this will be behind me
soon i'm just waiting on him to just do
do some all the little right things to
show me that this is what you really
want
and then this will be behind me i'm not
stuck i'm not stuck here yeah
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking of doing this
um
the advice i would give to a young girl
else
she shouldn't that's the advice
and i will be able to give her advice
because i live this life
and if you're not strong
it'll break you it'll break you so i
would say she shouldn't
yeah and what's the most important
lesson you've learned the most important
lesson i've learned
is
not to believe what you hear you have to
see it
put it in action because a person can
make their mouth say anything and that's
the thing that kind of like caught
me all these good talks all this good
game
all these fairy tales you didn't tell me
and then now
that none of them perceive so i would
say that taught me
to just um don't believe
too much of what you hear you have to
see it in action
all right spicy thank you so much thank
you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome it's been a pleasure yes
yes thank you so much